in the last videos a little formal and
defining what what RN is and what a
vector is and and and what vector
addition or scalar multiplication is in
this video I want to kind of go back to
basics it just give you a lot of
examples and give you a more tangible
sense for what vectors are and how we
operate with them so let me define a
couple of vectors here so let me and I'm
going to do most of my vectors I'm going
to do in this video are going to be an
r2 and that's because they're easy to
draw are to remember r2 is the set of
all two tuples ordered ordered two
tuples where each of the number so you
know you can have X 1 X 1 and let me see
the my 1 looks like a comma X 1 and X 2
where each of these are real numbers so
each of them X 1 is a member of of the
reals
X 1 and X 2 is a member of the reals and
just to make you give you a sense of
what that means if this is right here is
my my coordinate axes and I wanted to
plot all my X ones X 2's right this
could be you know you could view this as
the first coordinate we always imagine
that as our x axis and then our second
coordinate we plotted on the vertical
axis that traditionally is our y-axis
but we'll just call that the second
number axis whatever you could visually
represent all of our two by literally
every single point on this plane if we
were to continue off in infinity in
every direction that's what our two is
our 1 would just be points just along
one of these number lines that would be
our 1 so you could immediately see that
our two is kind of a bigger a bigger
space but anyway I said that I wouldn't
be too abstract I would be I would show
you examples so let's let's get some
vectors going in r2
so let me define my vector a I'll make
it nice and bold my vector a is equal to
make some numbers up negative 1 2 and my
vector B V make it nice and bold let me
make that is
I don't know three three one those are
my two vectors now let's just let's just
add them up and see what we get just
based on my definition of vector vector
addition and I'll just stay in one color
for now so I don't have to keep
switching back and forth so a nice deep
a-plus bolded B is equal to I just add
up each of those terms negative one plus
three and then two plus one that was my
definition of vector addition so that is
going to be equal to two two and three
fair enough this just came out of my
definition of vector addition but how
can we represent these this vector so we
already know that if we have coordinates
you know if I have the coordinate and
this is just a convention it's just the
way that we do it the way we visualize
things if I wanted to plot the point 1
comma 1 I go to my coordinate axes the
first point I go along the horizontal
what we traditionally call our x-axis
and I go one in that direction and then
the convection is the second point I go
one in the vertical direction so the
point 1 1
I would sorry let me be very clear this
is 2 & 2 so 1 is right here and 1 is
right there so the point 1 1 would be
right there that's just the standard
convention now our convention for
representing vectors are you might be
simply 0 maybe I just represent this
vector at the point minus 1/2 and on
some level you can do that and I'll show
you a second but the convention for
vectors is that you can start at any
point any point let's say this where
we're dealing with 2-dimensional vector
so you can start at any point in r2 so
let's say that you're starting at the
point so let's say that you start at the
point x1 and x2 this could be any point
any point in r2 in r2 to represent this
vector what we do is we draw a line from
that point to the point x1 and let me
call this let's say that we wanted to
draw a so x1 minus 1 so this is I'm
representing a so this is I want to
represent the vector a x1 minus 1 and
then x1 plus 2 now that that if that
seems confusing to you when I draw it
will be very obvious so let's say I just
want to start at the point let's just
say for you know for quirky reasons I
just pick a random point here I just
pick a point that one right there that's
my starting point so minus 4 comma 4
that's minus 4 comma 4 now if I want to
represent my vector a what what I just
said is is that I add I add the first
term in vector a to my first coordinate
so X 1 plus minus 1 or X 1 minus 1 so my
new one is going to be so this is my X 1
minus 4 so now it's going to be let's
see I'm starting at the point minus 4
comma 4 if I want to represent a what I
do is I draw an arrow 2 minus 4 plus
this first term minus 1 and then 4 plus
the second term 4 plus 2 and so this is
what this is minus 5 comma 6 so I go to
minus 5 comma 6 so I go to that point
right there and I just draw a line so my
vector will look like this I draw a line
from there to there and I draw an arrow
at the end point so that's one
representation of the vector minus 1/2
actually let me do it a little bit
better because minus 5 is actually more
a little closer right here minus 5 comma
6 is right there so I draw my vector
like that like that but remember this
point minus 4 comma 4 was an arbitrary
place just to draw my vector I could
have started I could have started at
this point here I could have started the
point 4 comma 6 and done the same thing
I could have gone minus 1 in the
horizontal direction
that's my movement in the horizontal
direction and then plus 2 in the
vertical direction so I could have drawn
so minus 1 in the horizontal and then
plus 2 in the vertical gets me right
there so I could have just as easily
drawn my vector like that these are both
interpretations of the same
vector a and I should draw them the
color of vector a so vector a was this
light blue color right there so this is
vector a this is vector a sometimes
it'll be a little arrow notation over
the vector but either of those reckon I
can draw an infinite number of vector a
is I could draw a vector a here I could
draw it like that
and vector a it goes back one back one
and up two so vector a could be right
there vector a similarly vector B what
does vector B do I could pick some
arbitrary point for vector B some zartra
point it goes to the right three so it
goes to the right one two three and then
it goes up one so vector B one
representation of vector B u looks like
this another representative I could
start could do it right here I could
start it right here I could go to the
right 3 1 2 3 and then up 1 this would
be another representation of my vector
of my vector B there's an infinite
number of representations of them but
the convention is to often put them in
what's called the standard position and
that's to start them off at 0 0 so your
initial point so let me write this down
standard position standard position is
just to start the vectors at 0 0 and
then draw them so vector a in standard
position I'd start at 0 0 like that and
I would go from I would go back 1 and
then up 2 so this is vector a in
standard position right there and then
vector B instead let me write that
that's a and then vector B in standard
position is 3 go to 3 right and then up
1 but these are the vectors in standard
position but any of these other things
we drew or just as valid just as valid
now let's see if we can get an
interpretation of what happened when we
added a plus B a plus B a plus B well if
I draw that vector in standard position
I just calculated now it goes to 3 so I
go to the right 2 and I go up 3 so if I
just draw it in standard position it
looks like the
it looks like this this vector right
there that vector right there and at
first when you look at it so this this
vector right here is the vector a plus B
in standard position when you draw it
like that it's not clear what the
relationship is when we added a and B
but to see the relationship what you do
is you put a and B head details and what
does that means you put the tail end of
B to the front end of a so if can
remember all of these are valid
representations of B all of the
representations of the vector B they all
have you can all their all parallel to
each other but they can start from
anywhere so another equally valid
representation of vector B is to start
at this point right here kind of the end
point of vector a in standard position
and then draw a vector B starting from
there so you go three to the right so
you go one one two three and then you go
up one so then you go up one so vector B
could also be drawn just like that just
like that
and then you should see something
interesting it happened and remember
this is this vector B representation is
not in standard position but it's just
an equally valid way to represent my
vector now what do you see when i add a
which is right here to be 2b what what
do i get if i connect the starting point
of a with the endpoint of b i get the
addition i have added I have added the
two vectors and I could have done that
anywhere I could have started with a
here and then I could have done the
endpoint of I could have done started B
here and gone 3 to the right 1 2 3 and
then up 1 and I could have drawn be
right there like that and then if I were
to add a plus B I go to the starting
point of a and then the endpoint of B
and I that should also be the visual
representation of a plus B and just to
make sure it confirms with this number
what I did here as I went to to the
right 1 2 and then I went 3 up 1 2 3 and
I got a plus B
now let's think about what happens when
we scale our vectors when we multiply it
by us but times some some scalar factor
so let me pick new vectors those have
got a monopoly monotonous let me define
vector V V for vector let's say that it
is equal to 1 2 so if I just wanted to
draw a vector V in standard position I
would just go one to the horizontal and
then 2 to the vertical that's it that's
the vector in standard position if I
wanted to do it in a non standard
position I could do it right here one to
the right up to look just like that
equally valid way of drawing vector V
equally valid way of doing it
now what happens if I multiply vector V
what if I have I don't know what if I
have 2 2 times V 2 times my vector V is
now going to be equal to 2 times each of
these terms so it's going to be 2 times
1 which is 2
and then 2 times 2 which is 4 now what
does 2 times vector V look like well let
me just start from an arbitrary position
let me just start right over here so I'm
gonna go 2 to the right 1 2 and I go up
4 1 2 3 4 so this is what 2 times vector
V looks like this is 2 times my vector V
and if you look at it it's pointing in
the exact same direction but now it's
twice as long and that makes sense
because we scaled it by a factor of 2
when you multiply it by a scalar you're
not changing its direction its direction
is the exact same thing as it was before
you're just scaling it by that amount
and I could draw this anywhere I could
have drawn it right here I could have
drawn 2 V right on top of V and then you
would have seen it and I don't want to
cover it you would have seen that it
goes it's exactly in this case when I
drew it in standard position its
collinear it's along the same line it's
just twice as far it's just twice as
long but they have the exact same
direction now what happens if I were to
multiply if I were to multiply - let me
say minus 4
times our vector V minus four times our
vector V well then that will be equal to
minus 4 times 1 which is minus 4 and
then minus 4 times 2 which is minus 8 so
this is my new vector minus 4 minus say
this is minus 4 times our vector V so
let's just start at some arbitrary point
now let's just do it in standard
position so you go to the right 4 or so
you go to the left 4 so 1 so you go to
left 4 1 2 3 4 and then down 8 look like
that so this new vector is going to go
and this is going to look like this I'll
make sure I can draw a relatively
straight line there you go so this is
minus 4 times our vector V I'll do
little arrow on it to make sure you know
it's a vector now what happened well
we're kind of in the same direction
actually we're in the exact opposite
direction but we're still along the same
line right we're just in the exact
opposite direction and it's this
negative it's the negative right there
that flipped us around if we just
multiplied negative 1 times this we
would have just flipped around 2 right
there
right when we multiplied it by negative
4 so we scale it by 4 so you make it
four times as long and then it's
negative so that it flips around it
flips backwards so we can now that we
have that notion we can kind of we can
start understanding the idea of
subtracting subtracting vectors let me
write make up to two new vectors right
now let's say my vector let's say my
vector X nice and bold X is equal to and
I'm doing everything in r2 but I'll do
it in the last part of this video I'll
make a few examples in r3 or r4 let's
say my vector X is equal to is equal to
2 4 and let's say I have a vector Y why
make it nice and bold and then that is
equal to that is equal to negative 1
minus 2 and I want to think about the
eye the notion of what X minus y is
equal to X
- why well we can say that this is the
same thing as X plus minus one times our
vector Y right so X plus minus one times
our vector Y now we can use our
definitions we know how to multiply by a
scalar so we say that this is equal to
let me switch colors I don't like this
color this is equal to our X vector is 2
4 and then what's -1 times y so minus 1
times y is minus 1 times minus 1 is 1
and then minus 1 times minus 2 is 2 so X
minus y is going to be these two vectors
added to each other right I'm just
adding the minus of Y this is this right
here is minus vector Y so this X minus y
is going to be equal to 3 and 3 and 6 so
let's see what that looks like when we
visually represent them our vector X was
2 4 so 2 4 in standard position it looks
like this standard position it looks
like this that's my vector X and then
vector Y in standard position let me do
it in a different color I'll do Y in
green vector Y is minus 1 minus 2 so
minus 1 minus 1 minus 2 so minus 1 minus
2 it looks just like this minus 1 minus
2 it looks just like this and actually
ended up inadvertently doing collinear
vectors but hey this is interesting too
so this is vector Y so then what's their
difference it says 3 6 so it's the
vector 3 6 so it's this vector let me
draw it someplace else so I start here I
go 1 2 3 and then I go up 6
so then up 6 it's a vector that looks
like this that's the difference between
the two vectors
so you say at first you say this is X
minus y you're like hey how does this
how is this the difference of these two
well if you if you overlay this if you
just shift this and over this you could
actually just start here and go straight
up and
see that it's really the difference
between the endpoints you're kind of
connecting the endpoints but what I
actually didn't want to draw cold in
your vector so let me do another example
although that one is kind of interesting
you often don't see that one in a book
let me define vector X in this case to
be to be 2/3 and let me define vector Y
to be minus minus 4 minus minus 2 so
what would be X in standard position it
would be 2/3 it looked like that that is
our vector X if we start at the origin
so this is X and then what does vector Y
I look like I'll do Y an orange minus 4
minus 2 so vector Y looks like this
vector Y will look like this now what is
X minus y X minus y well you know we
could view this 2 plus minus 1 times
this we could just say 2 minus minus 4 I
think you get the idea now but we just
did it the first way the last time
because I wanted to go from my basic
definitions of scalar multiplication so
X minus y is just going to be equal to 2
plus minus 1 times minus 4 or 2 minus
minus 4 that's the same thing as 2 plus
4 so it's 6 and there's 3 minus minus 2
so it's 5 right so the the difference
between the two is the vector 6 5 so you
could you could draw it out here again
so you could go to add 6 to 4 you go up
there and then to 5 you'd go like that
so the vector would look something like
this to curve like that so that's X
minus y but if we drew them between like
in the last example I showed that you
could draw it between their two heads so
if you do it here what does it look like
well if you start at this point right
there you start at that point right
there and you go 6 to the right so you
go 6 to the right and then up 5
you end up right there so the difference
between the two vectors let me make sure
I get the difference between the two
vectors looks like that it looks just
like that which kind of should make
sense intuitively X minus y that's the
difference between the two vectors
- you can view the difference is how do
you get from one vector to another
vector right like if you know let's get
and go back to our kind of our second
grade world of just scalars if I say
what seven minus five is and you say
it's equal to two well that just tells
you that five plus two is equal to seven
or the difference between five and seven
is two and here you're saying look the
difference between x and y is this
vector right there it's equal to that
vector right there or you could say look
if I take five and add two I get seven
or you could say look if I add if I take
vector Y and I add vector X minus y then
I get vector X now let's do something
else that's interesting let's do what Y
minus X is equal to Y minus X what is
that equal to do it another color right
here well we'll take minus 4 minus 2
which is minus 6 and then you have minus
2 minus 3 it's minus 5 so Y minus X is
going to be let's see because if we
start here we're going to go down 6 1 2
3 4 5 6 and then back 5 so back to 4 5
so Y minus X looks like this Y minus X
looks like that it's really the exact
same vector remember it doesn't matter
where we start it's just pointing in the
opposite direction so if we shifted it
here I could draw it right on top of
this it would be the exact as X minus y
but just in the opposite direction which
is this a general good thing to know so
you can kind of view them as the
negatives of each other and actually let
me make that point very clear you know
we drew why why I drew before actually
let me draw X X we could draw is 2 3 so
you go to the right 2 and then up 3 I've
done this before this is X a
non-standard position
that's X as well what is negative x
negative X is minus 2 minus 3 so if I
were to start here I'd go to minus 2 and
then I go minus 3 so minus X would look
just like this minus X so it looks just
like X it's parallel it has the same
magnitude it's just pointing in the
exact opposite direction and this is
just a good thing to kind of really get
seared into your brain is to have an
intuition for these things now just I
kind of finish up just to finish up this
this kind of the idea of adding and
subtracting vectors let me just do
everything I did so far was in an r2 but
I want to show you that we can
generalize them and we can even
generalize them to two vector spaces
that aren't aren't normally intuitive
for us to to actually visualize so let
me define a couple of vectors let me
define vector let me define vector a to
be equal to 0 minus 1 2 & 3 let me
define vector B to be equal to 4 minus 2
0 5 we can do the same addition and
subtraction operations with them it's
just it'll be hard to visualize but we
can keep them in just vector form and
and so we won't so that they're still
useful to think in 4 dimensions so if I
were to say 4 times a 4 times a this is
the vector a minus 2 times B what is
this going to be equal to and this is a
vector what is this going to be equal to
well we could rewrite this as 4 times
this whole column vector 0 minus 1 2 & 3
minus 2 times B minus 2 times 4 minus 2
0 5 and what is this going to be equal
to this term right here 4 times this
you're going to get you're going to get
actually the pen tablet seems to not
work well there so I'm going to do it
right here 4 times this you're going to
get 4 times 0 0 minus 4 8 4 times 2 is 8
4 times 3 is 12
and then - I'll do it in yellow - 2
times 4 is 8 2 times minus 2 is minus 4
2 times 0 is 0 2 times 5 is 10 now this
isn't a good part of my board so let me
just it doesn't right well right over
there I haven't figured out the problem
but if I were to just write it over here
what do we get what do we get with 0
minus 8 minus 8 minus 4 minus 4 minus
negative 4 so that's minus 4 plus 4 so
that's 0 8 minus 0 is 8 12 minus what
was this I can't even read it what it
says this was a 10 no now you can see it
again something it's very bizarre
2 times 5 is 10 so it's 12 minus 10 so
it's 2 so when we take this vector and
multiply it by 4 and subtract 2 times
this vector we just get this vector and
even though even though you can't
represent this in kind of an easy kind
of graphic graphical format this is a
useful concept we're going to see this
later when we apply the sum of these
vectors to multi-dimensional spaces